Birds are living
dinosaurs, and that shift
is one of the most
spectacular transitions
in the history of life.
This year, researchers studying
both fossils and modern birds
figured out how one
group of dinosaurs
became smaller, more adaptable.
The change happened
pretty quickly,
setting the stage for
the avian explosion--
the arrival of modern birds.
Think Frankenstein meets
the Fountain of Youth.
Researchers stitched
two mice together--
one young one
old-- and connected
their circulatory systems.
The connection
rejuvenated the brain
and the muscle of
the older mouse.
It appears young blood contains
a factor that can turn back
the clock on the aging process.
This year, several teams shows
that robots, like people,
can accomplish more
by working together.
In one study, 1,000 robots, each
the size of American quarter,
joined together like a marching
to form squares and letters
and shapes.
Another team,
inspired by termites,
designed a robot
swarm that built
three-dimensional structures.
Researchers who
make computer chips
are breaking from
their old ways.
In 2014, they created the first
large-scale neuromorphic chips.
These chips are designed
to process information
in ways that are more
like a living brain.
The chips could make it easier
for machines to carry out
perceptual tasks,
such as vision.
And more capable robots could
also deal with a lot of data
from sophisticated
environmental sensors.
Scientists who work
with stem cells
have reached a long-sought goal.
They turned human stem cells
into pancreatic beta cells
that can secrete insulin.
These important
cells are missing
in people who have
type 1 diabetes.
But doctors can't yet transplant
the new cells into patients.
That's because the cells
would be rejected as foreign.
Still, the achievement
brings a possible treatment
for diabetes one step closer.
When it comes to
ancient cave art,
researchers have long
believed that Europe
held the world's
oldest examples.
But this year,
researchers announced
that a cave in Indonesia holds
hand prints and paintings
that they believe
are 35,000 years old.
The find suggests that
modern humans were pretty
creative by the time they
left Africa and began
settling the rest of the world.
In 2013, brain scientists
made a cool but kind
of creepy discovery.
They could instill a fake
memory of fear in mice.
To do it, they manipulated
neurons with light.
And this year, they took
the method one step further.
They used a similar technique
to switch good memories
to fearful ones and bad memories
to more pleasant recollections.
In 2014, researchers launched
a record number of cube sats
into space.
A cube sat is a pint-sized,
low-cost satellite.
But they're starting to
do some real science.
They're cheap and
easy to launch,
and they can carry
very powerful sensors.
That means in time,
constellations of cube sats
may do the job that now takes
a single, complex, and pricey
mission.
The DNA code usually
includes just four letters--
G, C, A, and T. But
this year, researchers
added a new pair of
letters-- X and Y.
And they managed to insert
these extra letters into living
bacteria.
Next up, they want to
use the extra DNA letters
to code for amino acids
that are not normally
part of the proteins
that organisms make.
And now, the
breakthrough of the year.
That is the sound of a comet.
It was recorded by the
Rosetta Spacecraft.
In August, after
a 10-year journey,
Rosetta became the first
probe to orbit a comet.
Then, in November, it
made history again,
dropping a small lander that
drifted to the comet's surface.
But the landing was awkward.
It bounced and ended
up in a place where
it couldn't recharge
its solar panels.
Still, it collected
a lot of data
before its batteries ran out.
Now Rosetta is
chasing the comet.
It's going to watch its
jets of gas and dust
turn on as the
comet nears the sun.
The results could
tell scientists
a lot about how our
solar system formed
and what brought water to Earth.